They never,
I don't know much about Moose there.
Awesome.
So fucking big.
Such a giant animal to one live boom.
Live with James Hetfield.
How I Sarah do an awesome friend of Jim
is a friend of mine.
So awesome to hear.
So yeah.
So you're in.
Hey Man,
I listened to your new Shit in the gym
today and you know,
what's amazing about it?
You guys still fucking rock hard,
you know,
you haven't.
I love aerosmith.
That was a huge aerosmith fan when I was
a kid,
but somewhere along the line they became
a ballot van somewhere along the line I
started doing movies for music,
for mood,
music,
for movies that appeal to like a
adolescent teenage girls.
You know,
like something happened.
Yeah,
I got,
you know.
And then other people start writing your
songs.
That's,
that's I think the,
the ultimate kind of uh,
uh,
not given up,
but you've,
you've,
you've lost your way.
Yeah.
But I wanted to talk to you about like
there's a transition that very
successful people make and either they
make it or they don't.
And the,
the,
the transition is to go from being
hungry and filled with all this anxious
to being like stupid,
wealthy and famous,
but still keeping your art relevant.
Like how do you do that?
Uh,
we're super competitive.
People were really perfectionists and we
hate to let each other down.
Uh,
there is a,
there's always a better riff coming.
There's always a better album.
Uh,
maybe there's the never satisfied part
to us that will keep us going til we
die.
You know,
there's always the ultimate lyric that's
going to connect to everyone in the
world or something.
There is always a better something that
we haven't got yet.
So is that mindset,
is that you.
I guess in the beginning you just want
to do it right?
You want to be a successful band?
Do you want to make it,
you're young,
you're filled with adjuncts,
but your music as a same sort of
intensity to it.
Like today in the gym,
I got in there,
I hadn't listened to your new album or
all.
I fucking cranked it up to nine and I
just said,
let's go.
And I turned it on and right from the
jump I was like,
whoa.
Like there's something about a good
fucking hard rock album that just gets
you pumped up and you guys are 100
percent a plus.
Succeeded with this one.
Awesome to hear.
Well that's,
that's why we do it too.
We write music,
we write music,
we record music that we want to hear
because we're not hearing it out there
sometimes.
So.
And that's how it's been since day one.
And uh,
you know,
as you were were pretty honest in our
music too.
So I love the fact that from album one
to here we're doing it our way and we're
writing songs for ourselves and that
there's an honesty that has to be in it
or people
can see.
People can see that shit on.
Yeah.
They're like little animals.
They smell it,
right,
don't they?
And they,
they smell,
they smell it the whole deal.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's refreshing to see a band that's
been at it for a long time that's super
successful.
That still goes after it.
Yeah.
The thing that,
the thing that bugs me a lot is when
people say,
you know,
okay,
now that you're now that you're sober or
now that you're matured now all this and
you've worked out all your inner demons
and things like that,
that your music's going to be all soft
and flowery and I tell Ya,
if,
if I could exercise all those demons I
would have and it,
but it just,
it's something you,
you embrace.
It's a part of me and I get to celebrate
it in my music.
I get to communicate it.
I get to use it as a therapy to help my
own insanity and other people do too.
So when you get those like minded people
together in a place and play live music
does something to people like you in the
gym.
I get to watch people at our shows
transform from God.
I just took my tie off or I still have
my frigging briefcase,
you know,
like handcuffed to me.
I want out of this and I get to let
loose and I get to see these people
transform and s and watch music.
Do stuff to them.
Yeah,
transforms the right word,
right,
because it does,
it's almost like music,
it,
I think there's an element of music that
doesn't get discussed that it does have
some sort of an effect on the body.
Like there's like when you hear a good
song and you're in your Cannula,
so it's like a drug.
I mean,
it is,
it's like taking,
taking a shot of this caveman nitrile is
more powerful than that really,
because it's instantaneous,
you know,
plenty of seating tickets.
Plenty.
Well that's the best place like for Lars
and I to listen to the music when we're
putting it together,
you know,
does it make the car test?
You know that,
that because you're yourself in your
car,
if no one else is in there,
uh,
you're,
you get to celebrate and listen and just
go frigging nuts in your car.
And that's the past,
the car test,
you know,
that's got to be where most people
listened to most of their music these
days with all the commuting people do.
Especially here in la.
It's a ridiculous place as where you
live in these totally.
We save people from road rage,
the kids just headbang people ramping it
up.
Well,
there's not too much shooting people in
cars anymore.
It was going on for awhile in the
nineties.
And as Trinity.
What do you live these days?
I live in Vail,
Colorado.
Oh no shit man.
Wow.
That's Kinda cool.
Is very cool.
It's quiet.
No frigging traffic.
Uh,
and especially now.
Super quiet snow.
A snow dose does something to calm you
down a little bit.
I agree with that.
I remember when I was a kid in Boston,
there was those days when it would just
snow hard.
He'd go outside and you experienced
quiet like it.
Never heard it before.
Right.
It's like everything filtered by that
snow.
Well,
I like,
you know,
there's a,
there's a lone wolf part of me that I,
I may,
maybe you can relate to,
but I like being by myself,
but I also like,
I need people to,
to connect with as well.
But when I get out,
uh,
you know,
living in Vail,
moving from California to Colorado was
a,
was a great thing for me.
I feel really ugh.
I feel a part of nature there.
Um,
and you don't want to be inside there.
There's something about it.
You just want to be outside all the
time.
What's so beautiful?
Yeah.
I'm going to Colorado this weekend.
[inaudible]
cool.
Yeah,
it's fucking stunning up there.
This is something about Colorado.
Those mountains are just the best
natural artwork like you could ever look
at.
Yeah,
no doubt.
We get to look at the Gore range right
out our mountain and I've drank plenty
of coors lights in my life and that's
the one on the can like,
wow.
I'm looking at it and uh,
lots of fourteeners there.
Lots of great,
uh,
you know,
lots of great snowmobiling,
rafting,
paddleboard and you name it.
It's a fourteener.
A 14,000
feet.
Pete peaks.
Oh,
14,000
feet.
The people who are in the climate,
those crazy peaks.
Yeah.
Or hunting,
you know,
what made you move out there?
Like,
what was the,
did you go there and visit first or just
decided you needed a separate from the
hive and.
Yeah,
there's probably a multitude of things
that made it happen.
My wife grew up there.
She was born in Argentina,
they moved to Vail,
she went to elementary school there,
you know,
we were going to Tahoe a lot to do
skiing and stuff like that.
And she said,
you gotta we gotta go to Vale,
this is,
this is not snow,
will go to Vail and feel snow.
And we went there a few times and I
loved it.
Now I'm not a huge skier,
but I can ski and have fun doing it.
My kids love it.
Um,
and so that my,
my wife turns into a kid when we go
there,
which I kind of like,
it's a little more like me,
you know,
she can be a little,
a little too on point and a little,
you know,
uh,
she's,
um,
she loosens up and she becomes young
again there.
Um,
so there's that kind of got sick of the
bay area,
the attitudes of people.
They're a little bit.
I was,
you know,
they talk about how diverse they are and
things like that and you know,
it's fine if you're diverse like them,
you know,
but,
showing up with a deer on the bumper
doesn't fly in Marin county,
you know.
Uh,
my,
my form of eating organic doesn't vibe
with theirs,
you know.
Did you,
do you have issues with that?
Like with the people you lived with up
in Marin county with hunting?
Or was it just something you felt?
Yeah,
you know,
it's something I felt,
uh,
I probably made it up in my head a
little bit.
Yeah,
because I'm pretty good at that.
Pretty creative and I can start fights
with myself in my head all the time.
A lot of people get.
Oh yeah,
but,
but there was,
there was just a,
I don't know,
I felt that there was an elitist
attitude there that if you weren't there
way politically their way,
uh,
you know,
environmentally all of that,
that uh,
you know,
you were looked down upon.
I think in Colorado everyone is very
natural.
People are not playing some game,
they're not posturing,
you know,
they're very into,
oh,
you like doing that?
Cool.
How's that go?
How you doing with that?
You know,
and they're,
they're,
they're less,
they're less obsessed with stopping what
you're doing and more enjoying what
they're doing.
You know?
That's interesting.
That's an interesting way to look at it.
I love the bay area,
but I've always felt like.
I think you nailed it.
The Bay area,
they love diversity as long as you're
diverse.
The way they're diverse.
It's um,
it's so tech oriented,
it's so absorbed with one aspect of
society,
technology and cell phones and the
Internet and electric cars and it's so
locked into that one sort of mode of
being that I think a guy like you goes
out there and shoot an elk or something
like that.
It's probably like a little creepy to
them.
Well,
I,
I just think I feel more at home in the
midwest or the mountains or something.
I mean,
I love the ocean and I love the bay
area.
I love what it's got to offer,
but there's just a,
just an attitude that it was,
uh,
it,
it wasn't healthy for me starting to
feel like,
uh,
I was just fighting all the time and I
just had to
get out of my own head.
So Colorado does it for me.
You were doing that show,
the hunt that,
uh,
that show that,
what is it on history channel or
something like that where it was all
about a grizzly bear hunting.
You were doing the narration for that.
Yeah.
And you,
I saw this crazy blow back because of
that where there was people were they
wanted a boycott at music festival that
you guys were on and,
and there was photos of another guy who
wasn't you or they're getting circled
around it.
We're saying it was you.
They killed a grizzly bear and they were
saying,
we have to ban this.
This is heartless.
Was very strange.
Like what was your reaction to all that?
I,
I kinda just took it as,
okay,
that's how it's been for me in the bay
area.
You know,
people don't understand it and I mean,
it's just like with anything,
you know,
I don't think they understand that
someone can be,
is passionate about something else,
as,
as passionate as they are about what
they are passionate about,
you know?
So if you're as a passionate about
something,
there's someone who's the opposite and
that's okay.
You can get along,
you can talk about it.
No one's right,
no one's wrong.
This is my life.
I like to live in it this way.
You like living your life that way.
I totally get it,
but we can coexist in this and let's
really be diverse,
you know,
for me going out,
whether it's planning my own vegetables,
having my own beehives,
getting our own honey,
a,
harvesting my own meat on the ranch.
That's what I love doing.
I love sustaining my family with as
organic as possible.
And uh,
you know,
I,
I respect people that don't want the
blood.
They don't want all that scene.
They would rather see their meat or
whatever it is,
show up in a nice cellophane package and
it's handed to them.
They don't want to know how it got
there.
I I respect that my kids are like that.
They don't want to see it going on,
but I want to be as close to the earth.
I want to be as part of it as possible.
I want to be part of every bit of it and
respect it.
Yeah.
I get that sentiment and I always found
it strange how many people get upset at
what you do,
but meanwhile they're eating meat.
I mean the San Francisco is filled with
restaurants that are serving meat.
Everywhere you go,
every single store you pass by has meat
in it and to focus on you for going out
and hunting is always a little weird.
Well,
I guess I'm more old school.
I don't know.
Whatever it is.
You know,
I think the bay area prides itself and
I'm glad there is a place that prides
itself on being progressive,
very moving forward.
Hey,
we're creating the future here and I
love the convenience and stuff of that,
but then there's a part of me that just
maybe is like frontier style.
I just love that.
I would rather be simple.
Mm,
well,
I think it's also probably you're
performing in front of fucking hundreds
of thousands of people all the time and
he just like Jesus Christ,
you need a balance.
I mean,
you need some sort of an opposite end of
the scale just to weigh things out.
Very true,
very true.
Uh,
you know,
what about me?
I want me time,
you know,
chill time,
quit pulling me all these different ways
and stuff.
Uh,
certainly not complaining.
That's what I choose to do.
But I also choose this too.
Well,
that's where a vail completely makes
sense.
So how long have you been raising bees?
Probably only,
maybe four years.
What,
how'd you get started in that?
How do you start raising bees?
Start with one.
We'll actually start with to really
know,
um,
they're not like rabbits,
but they do produce quite quickly,
you know?
Uh,
my dad raised bees,
uh,
I just,
we always saw boxes out in the corner of
the house.
We grew up in la here,
you know,
the weather's so great.
So there's lots of activity.
That's the bummer about being in Vale
now.
Not a lot of,
not a lot of action going on.
It's too high,
it's too cold and you know,
certain vegetables grow there but not a
lot.
But uh,
in California,
the ranch love,
I love it.
I got to see,
I had a friend who in his backyard,
he,
he probably had six hives and he had
this one really intense kind of rogue
hive where maybe the queen had some kind
of strain of a africanized or something
and her wife could not,
his wife could not go out in the
backyard without being attacked,
you know.
So he says,
Hey,
can I go put my bees on your property so
they can cycle this queen out,
you know,
they got some breeding in.
It was just off Jesus Christ.
So he,
he brought it out to the ranch,
he pinched the B and then a pinch.
The queen pinched it.
What do you mean killed it?
And then she's crying.
It's a nice euphemism.
You didn't have to shoot it or nothing,
you know,
hold still.
So he just grabbed the queen and killed
her.
Well has pinched.
It could because she was reproducing.
I mean,
they lay a million eggs in their lives.
It's insane that,
I mean,
I,
I basically,
I could sit here and talk a whole hour
about bees because they're so
interesting.
Let's do it.
Alright,
well the listener,
I'm not scaring.
No,
they listen.
They'll listen.
Trust me.
It's interesting stuff.
So yeah.
But it put a new queen in there and
they,
they cycled through all of the other bs.
I mean,
they only live a month.
So what is it?
And so a normal reaction when people go
in the yard would be,
they would just disinterest.
They wouldn't care about you as long as
you're not interrupting the hive.
Exactly.
But your wife would go out there and
they would just get crazy.
Yeah.
It was.
So you.
Oh yeah.
This wasn't me.
This was my friend's wife.
That's right.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
I mean he,
he's kind of used to it and she was not.
She was out to go swimming or go out
there and they would,
they would get crazy with him,
but he's like,
it just doesn't bother me.
But she was like,
fuck this queen.
Fuck this hive.
Yeah,
yeah,
pretty much.
And there's certain things if we're in
black,
they all attack.
You almost think you're a bear.
You know what?
Yeah.
Uh,
if you like just eaten banana's,
there's some,
I dunno,
a smell or a something in it that is
similar to their attack pheromone that
they set off.
So there's a few things I've learned
over the years,
Tony and bananas and don't,
don't wear black.
Exactly.
That's all you gotta do.
But I learned this stuff being in the
bee club.
You're going to be club.
Yeah.
In,
uh,
in,
in the bay area.
Yeah.
We'd meet down at the American Legion
Hall and have a monthly meeting.
One of those dorks like me and my buddy.
Oh my God,
we would just sit there and kind of
laugh about him.
Uh,
but we're sitting,
we're here to learn some stuff,
but there were people up there,
okay.
We inseminated the queen with this and
you know,
that we're counting bs,
we put little numbers on every B and
we've caught their flight pattern and
how many were reproducing this.
And I mean it,
it's all,
you know,
it's all a,
like,
uh,
they're,
they're doing research on how to make
the be stronger because the bees are
going away.
But um,
you know,
it's,
this might this little a Varroa mite
that's killing a lot of them too,
along with the pesticides and
herbicides,
but,
uh,
you know,
people that are so into it and we're
just gonna sit in there going home,
man,
what have we gotten ourselves into?
But it's Kinda,
you know,
it's funny in a certain way,
but I'm glad that it's happening.
But,
uh,
you know,
I get it at the end of the season,
you get like 500 pounds of honey and
you're handing them out to your friends
and everyone's loving it.
Five hundred pounds of honey.
That's insane.
Yeah.
And we're bottling it up.
My kids are filtering it,
we're bottling it up and it,
dude,
it's just straight from the hive into a
bottle.
I mean,
after you've filtered it.
And it really helps with allergies.
It helps with,
uh,
you know,
the whatever,
getting the pollens and the,
and the nectar is from the area.
So when you take that in and it helps
build your immune system.
Yeah,
I've heard that.
So you've experienced that person.
Absolutely.
And I think being stung by bees helps
you to.
It helps with,
with something getting your,
your immune system built up to.
It's supposed to be really good for
arthritis.
They,
they take people like literally take
bees,
people that are,
that have serious arthritis in their
hands and they sting their hands with it
on purpose.
Right.
I think there's some people that do it
for their lips here in la.
I think you need people that are so
deep,
deep into the pe world because you're
not going to do it.
I'm not going to do it,
but if someone's just so far gone,
they're measuring all their bs and
monitoring their flight patterns and
checking their DNA.
I'm just fascinated that there was a
clear differentiation between a normal b
and the way these bees were behaving
that you could tell that the queen was
kind of a freak,
but Italia,
those freak beast,
the Africanized or whatever.
Now there's a Zombie bee and we can.
We can get into that too,
but uh,
they are,
they are aggressive and an aggressive,
you know,
it's like any society,
they do well,
they,
they get most,
they produce a lot of honey and they,
they,
they're very,
very prolific in what they do,
you know?
Yeah.
I've had killer bee honey.
They make killer bee.
Like what sounded good on it.
I don't know if he knows any better if
it's a killer bee honey better than
regular honey,
but just pretty dope to have killer bee
honey around your house.
Well,
yeah,
you know,
that.
And the um,
uh,
Gosh.
Oh,
what's this stuff called?
I mean there's,
there's lots of really cool healing
properties in,
in like even the,
the,
the kind of glue that they use to plug
up holes and you know,
uh,
the Royal Jelly,
which is,
you know,
comes from there,
like the brain and it,
that's how they produce a queen.
I mean,
there's so royal jelly is.
Yeah.
It's from their brains.
Brain juice,
man.
Holy Shit.
How does it come out?
Is it come out of a hole somewhere?
A,
what?
Do they have to scoop it out of their
fucking heads?
I haven't seen it that close,
but they injected into the,
injected,
into the queen cell or there's a cell
that they make when a new queen is being
made to all the bees that are flying
around that you see out here,
you know,
they're all females.
It's a huge.
It's all female society.
So the drones that are in there,
which were the males,
they're there just to reproduce and then
they get kicked out in the wintertime
and they didn't all die.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Yeah,
man.
It's hard outside.
Brutal.
Brutal for us men in the B world.
So if they all die,
how do they continue to reproduce?
Well,
there's some,
I guess the couple stay on.
They,
they,
the queen makes more.
Wow.
So those guys are just dead.
The Queen makes more on the new ones.
Takeover.
The new boys.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and they're just doing work.
They're just there.
They're just fertilizing.
That's what they're doing.
They're just there to fuck.
And then everybody else doing all the
real word fuck and go die.
That's what you get to do.
What a brutal world.
That's what a fucking crazy world.
And then the queen goes around the hive
and finds the females,
other,
other potential queens and stabs them
while they're in the hive.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
Well they're,
they're all females.
All females.
Septa for those drones.
And then you know,
if there's,
if they're making a,
you know,
she knows she's going to die or they're,
they're kind of pissed off with her.
She's not reproducing as much as she
should.
She will take off with half the hive and
that's why you see a swarm.
So she'll go and form a new hive and
then these ones have a little queen cell
that they've laid eggs and start to make
a new queen.
So that's how they reproduce.
And if there's three or four queen cells
in there,
the first queen that's born,
she comes out and she kills all the
other Queens so she can rule game of
thrones type shit.
That's fascinating.
And you're going to get bs.
I can tell them from right now looking
in my head,
I'm just looking at websites in my hand.
I'm like trying to find out where to get
the bees.
Yeah,
that sounds like an amazing way to get
honey.
I mean,
it just sounds like a really cool thing
to do to taste so good.
And we've got,
you know,
we,
we have a place in Hawaii so we've got
Hawaiian flavored Hawaiian flavored.
Well there's stuff,
you know,
that they,
they,
uh,
get the nectar and pollen from over
there and had Hawaii's nonstop.
Yeah.
So you're getting honey year round.
What island and Maui.
Oh Man,
I love Maui.
That's a beautiful spot.
Um,
so when you,
how do you know
that a b is Africanized?
Because that was the big thing that
everybody was worried about.
You remember it was like the early
nineties.
Everybody's like,
can we say,
found an African killer bee and no next
echo or something?
And was like,
it's coming up.
It's gonna,
it's gonna Swarm.
They going to take over the country.
And inside of a few years there was a
big hysteria about that,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
and there are,
there are states where there are more
prevalent than others and they're just
more aggressive or more aggressive in
their,
uh,
they're,
they're very protective.
So you'll get stung if you're messing
with them to,
that's all it is.
There's nothing so.
But we,
there was a big concern that they were
going to take hold and that it was going
to be that these bees,
we're just gonna come here and outbreed
the regular bs and I hear laughing,
remember possible?
Oh yeah,
for sure.
There's some great movies about that
too,
you know,
the killer bees,
but there's no way to tell by looking at
them.
I don't know.
I don't think so.
I'm somewhat into it,
but I haven't,
haven't investigated that part yet.
So these bees that came over from the,
perhaps africanized bees that when they
killed the queen and then introduce
those bees to the rest of the bs that
everybody chill out.
Yeah.
So it's just that one crazy bitch.
Well,
yeah,
she,
you know,
she's laying the eggs,
she's passing on the whatever DNA.
Uh,
but those are the,
uh,
the,
the forage or bees,
the ones that you see out and about.
They only live a month so they will die
out.
And how long did she live?
She can live between one to five years.
Wow.
What a bizarre culture stream.
Really,
really cool.
And without them,
I mean you're,
there's lots of,
uh,
you know,
orange almonds,
all kinds of stuff,
especially here in California and the,
you know,
in the,
uh,
in the center,
a center of California,
all that farming.
If there's no bs,
there's no fruit.
Yeah.
What a bizarre sort of symbiotic
relationship that we have with some one
weird insect pollination.
I mean,
you would've thought that that would
have been taken care of some other way
and it wouldn't be that a baby has to do
it.
Well,
there are others that do it.
What other butterflies?
And I'll tell you,
not just honeybees,
but there's,
there's probably over 3000 different
kinds of bees there.
They don't have,
they don't have a hive society like the
honeybees do,
but all these other bees are like
loners.
They're,
they live in the ground or something and
they just,
they just get enough pollen for
themselves,
so they're kind of lone lone wolves out
there,
but the honeybees are the ones that have
more of a society.
I raised chickens and the chicken thing
with us happened.
We just got a couple of chickens and the
next thing you know,
we got this giant fucking chicken house
at 23 chickens and they're running
around my yard.
Is that the same way with the leg?
Just kind of like slowly step into this
and then get deeper and deeper?
Yeah.
Let me just like getting your first
tattoos,
like,
yeah.
Wow,
that's cool.
I want more.
And uh,
yeah,
you just start to appreciate it.
I think when I come off tour it's like
my head is like ricocheting around in
there a,
a,
a goal.
When I sit and watch the bees,
just watch them go in and out,
in and out.
There's like this frigging landing strip
that he come in and they look so busy,
it relaxes me.
It's like,
wow,
okay.
I'm not that busy,
just cool.
Just chill.
No.
Is there a way,
do you like a glass wall in any way
where you can see into the hive?
You ever seen those hives where they
make them?
Do you have it like that?
We can look in there.
Yeah.
I've got one of the.
Well,
oh that's like a display one would bring
into schools and see I don't have one of
those but I got a couple of different
kinds of hives and it's fun to see,
you know,
sometimes you have the frames that I'm
already kind of prebuilt and then they
just deposit their stuff in it or you'll
watch them grow their own comb from
nothing and it's pretty amazing.
How do you get them to stay there
though?
Like how does it work?
Like I see those boxes and I know that
bees do have hives in those boxes,
but how does it initially start?
Well,
it's the queen.
Wherever the queen is,
that's where they go.
So she decides to be in that.
So how do you get her to stay in that
box?
Uh,
do you have a place for her to lay eggs?
I mean,
that's.
Yeah.
And she will stay and if she's there,
you know when they go off to to swarm to
go find a new hive.
If you've ever seen a swarm up in a
tree,
just like a giant,
like football size or even bigger,
a shape of just bs at Queen is right in
the middle and they're all just around
her and then they send off the scouts to
find a new spot.
They come back say,
hey,
it's over here to do the little wiggle
dance and that shows them how to get
there.
And they all go there.
We had an incident once on fear factor
where we covered these people with bs.
There was like a beekeeper there and he
had his hives and a local hive came over
and a group of bees came over and met
with these bees and we had a clear the
area out and they had to have a
conversation.
Like literally what happened.
They were in the air just floating
around and then they worked it out and
then the rbs came back and they went
back to the hive and the bees went about
their business.
They were just like,
what the fuck's going on?
You guys moving in here?
Like what are you doing?
Territorial.
Somehow or another,
they worked it out though.
There was no death,
there wasn't be fucking braveheart war.
It just,
they figured it out.
Had a good negotiator.
I don't want to.
What do they communicate with any living
these in pheromones.
Like how are they?
Smells.
Smells and dances.
Dances,
yeah.
Some B will find it.
Like,
hey man,
I found like a garden somewhere and
they'll come back and they'll see them
do the little wiggle thing.
It's like how many wiggles this way?
And then they turned left and then turn
that way.
That's,
that's like
a half a mile this way and then that,
that way.
And then they all learn it and then they
go for,
hey,
I found some water,
here's a place to go.
So they literally can tell them where
something is.
But the movements.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
That's crazy.
So it's almost like a,
like a body language pretty much.
And they all know it somehow.
Instinctively.
Yep.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's pretty bizarre.
There's a lot to learn about those
things.
That's really bizarre.
Yeah.
I didn't know that they can tell each
other where something is just by
wiggling,
like they have like this means a mile.
That means go left.
Wow,
man.
I can get.
I'm going to get deep and bs,
man.
What the fuck have you done?
All right.
Yeah.
And there's,
I'm sure there's probably a feel of
like,
wow,
I'm,
there's a whole society right here in my
yard and I'm,
I'm overseeing it,
you know,
there's probably a sense of importance.
Uh,
but you know,
I lay off of.
I mean there are people that are
checking them all the time and this and
that and oh,
you got to put the,
the certain pads in there to kill the
Mites and you gotta do this and that.
It's like another natural man.
They've been around longer than we have.
So just let them go.
They know what they're doing.
I don't know who,
who's to say I know what I'm doing with
them.
Do they need specific types of plants
around them in order to survive?
Yeah.
Well,
something that they can pollinate.
And you know,
it's from a,
it's good to plant,
you know what I've planned,
I've planted stuff that,
you know,
okay,
it blooms in the spring and then there's
other stuff that blooms in the summer
and then there's other stuff that
blooms,
you know,
like in the late summer.
So they've always got something going
on.
But they hibernate.
They hibernate in the winter.
No kidding.
Like bears.
Yep.
So when you are in Vail and you,
uh,
you have obviously a really cold weather
in the winter,
what do they do?
They just shut down and stay in the hive
and don't move.
Well,
uh,
I don't have bees in vail yet and I'm
going to try and figure out how to do
that.
But uh,
they,
I mean just like cattle,
you know,
your winter room down in the lowlands.
So,
uh,
I haven't found a place to,
to have bees go where there,
you know,
there's less snow,
but I'll,
I'll figure something out because it's
something I love doing.
It sounds amazing.
So in California you have a whole ranch,
like you have,
like you're totally like a prepper,
almost your sustainable.
Are you sustainable out their well
water?
You Bet.
Yeah.
That's a dream of mine.
It is awesome.
I'll tell you,
and that's a place I could just go up
and disappear.
I love it man.
And just get lost.
Just get lost in the anything.
Get lost in detail.
I got lots of fun stuff up there,
you know,
quads and you know,
I've got my welder and whatever.
I just get lost in things and I love it.
Uh,
you know.
Yeah.
You know,
hunting deer,
Turkey,
uh,
stuff that we eat the hunted off in the
ranch.
That's a,
that's such a beautiful thing,
man.
I remember hearing about Neil Young's
place that he's got some giant ranch up
there and Neil young and just chills out
and apparently has speaker set up around
a lake where he can be on a boat and
push the boat out into the middle of the
lake and the speakers will broadcast.
It's perfectly set up because you know,
he's a serious audio file.
Do you ever see his MP3 thing that he
created?
It didn't really catch.
Catch on.
Yeah.
It didn't really catch on for some
reason because people were just so
attached to listen to music on their
phones now,
but it's,
it's an amazing little device and it
just did that to,
to really put that much effort and
intention into something that's not
really necessary in the modern world.
Just shows you what a serious audio file
that guy is.
Yeah.
He loves it.
He loves music.
He loves the nature as well.
And I've been up to his ranch.
It's really cool.
We played the Neil Young,
uh,
bridge school benefit like three times
and he invites people out there to the
ranch.
It's beautiful.
It has buffalo out there and it seemed
acres.
Does he have out there a lot?
A lot.
I didn't count or something like that.
Yeah.
Wow.
But yeah.
Beautiful.
You know?
Yeah.
I mean,
for a guy like you,
that is,
I mean,
think,
I think you've found like this really
amazing and enviable balance between the
arena shows and all the fucking
craziness of rock and then Chirp,
Chirp,
Chirp.
Like you've Kinda like,
ouch.
Ouch fucker flap.
It's really kinda cool man.
Like you've,
I mean,
and also like being sober,
like you've Kinda like found this
interesting piece.
Yeah.
Slowly.
I'm not there yet,
but you know,
it uh,
more will be revealed,
you know,
it's uh,
it's a journey and I,
once I realized that it's just a
journey,
I'm okay with it,
you know,
um,
someone on a,
another interview was just asking me,
hey,
you know,
back in the early days you guys released
an album almost every year,
you know,
you've got like five,
five albums in six years or something.
And what happened?
That was eight years since the last one
is like,
dude,
there's a lot more life to do.
You know,
there's a lot,
you know,
vacations with families watching my kids
grow up.
Um,
uh,
you know,
touring a lot longer than it used to be,
Shit.
Back in those days we had this many
songs and this is how many gigs we can
do and then we're back in the studio.
So a lot is happening in life and uh,
everyone in the band is on the same
page,
which is really a great thing.
Um,
we've all got kids,
we've all got other lives,
but we can't live without metallica
event.
It's just something that joins us,
you know,
where these frigging for married guys
that know more about each other than
anyone knows about us.
Maybe our wives,
but you know,
the fact,
you know,
Lars and I have known each other for 35
years.
Wow.
Even maybe 36.
But I tell you that I've don't,
I,
there's nobody else I've known longer
except for maybe family than large.
So it's a brother,
he's a brother.
I hate him.
I love him.
I want to kill him.
I want to hug him.
All that,
all that stuff,
man.
Well,
it's also you.
I mean,
I,
I got to imagine that you,
you guys have to realize what an
unbelievably fortunate and amazing
experience you guys are on.
How many people have a dream when their
kids are being a fucking rock star?
How many people get to be in Metallica?
It's crazy,
dude.
I wake up everyday and think I'm
fricking blessed.
I mean,
this is unbelievable.
What if I complain once today punched me
in the face,
you know,
this is stupid,
exact,
so stupid that I would complain about
something.
Um,
but I tell you,
it is hard at times being on the road
doing stuff and when you don't want to
do stuff,
you do it.
But then you find something,
you find someone,
you find a thing and it's usually
someone in the crowd that's just,
you know,
I see myself right there.
It's like I'm that kid right there at
the motorhead concert looking up at.
Let me go on.
This is Paul Guy.
And so I just suck that energy and go,
all right,
this is a,
this is all I need.
This is all I need right now.
That's beautiful.
That was a hard one right when lenny
lenny died.
We went hard to the end.
No doubt he really did.
He fucking war.
That breaks out or the tires out fucking
screeched right into the rocks.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
And he didn't want anyone to know that
it was really that sick and he just kept
going.
And God,
that's what he knew and it's what he
loved.
And it's what he was.
And you know,
for me,
I thought the man was immortal,
you know,
he was just this icon of a figure,
uh,
the,
you know,
he was the godfather of heavy music for
us.
Without him,
there certainly wouldn't be a Metallica,
certainly wouldn't.
He was a,
he was the catalyst for Lars and I
getting together,
you know,
the ad in the paper,
we like bands.
Like motorhead was like,
hey,
somebody else liked motorhead.
Alright,
ads in the paper.
Is that crazy?
When you stop and think about that,
that's how you got back.
That's how you guys get together back
then.
That's how you found band members ads in
the paper looking for a drummer.
He goes straight to them.
Each section,
you know,
all the,
the,
you know,
uh,
the classifieds,
you know,
pass up all this stuff.
Just get right to age,
sit heavy metal.
I was like,
oh,
there's my ad.
And there's his,
we should meet.
There's only two of us.
Well,
you guys have been through such a
fascinating change in music too,
because I mean obviously lars was a huge
figure in the controversy surrounding
mp3s and that was like during the
napster days.
That was the time where everybody
realized like,
Holy Shit,
something just happened,
you know,
and I don't think we realized it back
then.
I think lars,
in a lot of ways was one of the first
people sounding the horn.
He was one of the first people going,
hey,
all this selling record shit is gonna go
away.
Like,
do you understand what's going on here?
People just taking things and putting
them online.
And this was a totally new thing.
Absolutely.
And
that poor guy still,
you know,
he's taken bullets.
He's taking hits for it still really?
Where,
oh everyone who's got a beef with any
other thing than a,
you know,
napster,
they,
it just gravitates towards that all the
time.
That poor guy.
Yeah.
He,
he got beat up by that and we all stood
behind him.
Obviously he was the spokesman for it.
He,
he,
he chose.
He chose to do that.
Management said,
hey,
this is coming,
let's be the ones that stand up for
artists.
And he took that.
He,
he grabbed the flag is that I'm going
and there were lots of other musicians
and people that were on board as well,
but they weren't as vocal or taking the
hits like he did.
There was something about,
you know,
even like a Dr Dre,
he was on board with it,
but for some reason in the rap world
it's like,
well,
it's all about money.
Anyway,
so,
so what is,
for heavy metal,
there was some kind of stigma around,
you know,
you,
you're,
you're an asshole if you're rich or if
you've been successful or something.
It's like we got to pull you down into
hell with us,
you know,
don't,
don't be getting good now.
You know?
Yeah.
So that was that stigma.
But there were other artists that would
show up at shows saying,
hey man,
I'm really glad you're doing what you're
doing.
It's like,
come on,
you know,
join us.
Oh No,
oh no.
My career would be over.
It's like,
you fuck,
you know,
it's so frustrating.
It's like,
dude,
do you believe in it?
Yeah.
Then stand up.
It's like,
yeah,
but no,
it will fall apart.
Something will happen.
My fans,
blah blah blah.
So they,
they were concerned about their own
careers and not the big picture of
artists.
And obviously these days you can see
there's no copyright laws,
there's no nothing,
man,
you can rip this and that and whatever
and do whatever you want with it.
There's a beauty to that and a lot of
creativity comes out of it,
but it gets watered.
It gets,
you know,
I dunno,
we,
we acknowledged that.
Yeah,
there's an inspiration somewhere for
everything blatantly taking that and
using it is,
it's pretty frustrating to me.
Um,
and we're,
we're,
we were at that point where we were,
we had a such a following.
We had such a strength in Metallica that
we survived all of that stuff.
Um,
but there was a lot of bands that
didn't,
you know,
uh,
they couldn't sustain themselves,
couldn't feed their families because of
what happened.
And I think the frustrating part was no
one really understood that music is our
life,
you know,
if you take that,
if you take our,
like the way we wanted to present our
music is part of the art.
Well again,
in an album,
meaning like one song leads to the next
song winning
well like releasing an album.
Here's how we'd like to release it.
We don't want it leaked over here.
We don't want this happening.
We don't know a present a presentation
is part of the art.
Like when you walk into an art studio,
the artist has been in there putting it
together like,
okay,
I want you to see this first.
And then that.
And then you go here and you get Bam,
you know,
that there's a passion behind that.
And when someone just throws it out
there,
then it kind of loses a leaves an
impact.
Um,
so if I'm complaining punched me in the
face,
but we have survived and we feel good
about it and we've adapted.
But the record companies certainly did
not,
you know,
they took it
a hard hit.
But also,
you know,
when you look at the record deals,
the deal that record companies make with
artists and you see like what,
what a record company selling,
well,
they're only selling your work without
your work,
without your creativity,
without your creations.
There's nothing to sell.
That's all they sell.
But then you look at these insanely one
side and deals that they cut with
artists,
especially emerging artists that might
be a little bit more desperate,
don't realize that potential,
especially the potential for income that
they might have in the future.
I mean,
I've seen some of those.
I don't know.
There was that one that somebody said
that courtly love didn't really write
it,
that it was ghost written.
I don't know who the fuck wrote it,
but courtly love put it out saying that
she wrote it,
but it was a breakdown of how artists
make money from the creation of an
artist,
a creation of an album to having it sold
and record stores to where the money
gets extracted and how much is left with
the actual artists.
It's pretty fucking disturbing.
Yeah.
Even A.
Well,
yeah.
A couple of years ago we,
we got the rights to our catalog or our
music from kill 'em all up until now we
own it finally,
which is weird.
My tell my kids,
Hey,
you know,
let's go celebrate.
We've got,
we got the master recordings,
we own it finally.
And they were just looking at me like,
what the hell are you talking about?
You wrote it,
why isn't it yours?
Okay,
well I'll have a little talk about how
it was back then.
You know,
you would somewhat sell a little bit of
your soul to get a bigger something,
you know,
it was basically the record company was
a bank and a marketing tool to get you
where you want it to be.
So uh,
you know,
it was a necessary thing at that time,
but it's great to have our stuff back
and be able to,
you know,
we own our own record press.
How cool is that?
Whoa.
In Germany,
one of our management people found a
place that had some machines that were
for sale and we bought one and so we
press our own vinyl man and we could
kind of do whatever we want.
What color vinyl today,
you know,
or what crazy things you can do,
uh,
you guys can kind of do whatever the
fuck you want now.
Right?
But you don't need a record company.
You do anything.
Well,
it depends.
Uh,
we have a record company.
We own our own in America or North
America.
The rest of the world is a little
tougher,
you know,
there's a lot of countries out there,
especially in Europe and there's no way
we can deal with the distribution in
each different country.
So we've cut really good deals with,
with other record companies that have a
vision and a,
have a love for Metallica and understand
that this is powerful stuff and people
love it and we want to be part of the
family.
Um,
but having your own record press is
pretty darn cool thing that was really
inspired by Jack White,
uh,
who,
you know,
white stripes,
fame,
they rec on tears.
He's done a lot of stuff,
but he,
he loves that stuff.
He's pressing his own stuff.
He's coming up with different ways of
doing vinyls and colors and hidden
tracks and cool stuff like that.
And it's,
it's just another way to get creative
in,
in your career is vinyl.
What's selling more than anything now
when it comes to actual physical hard
copies of things,
I don't know the numbers and they're
probably very all over the place,
but vinyl has never gone away and it's,
it's,
I don't know if it's coming back,
but it's more popular than it was.
I think there's just something tactile
about it.
There's something great that people are
finally understanding that you can look
at artwork,
you can feel it.
And then the,
the,
the ritualization of opening up the
player,
taking it out and blowing on it,
clean and it putting it down,
setting the needle down.
And it's something really cool.
I just,
I came down to La a few months ago and
hung out with some high school buddies.
It's like,
Hey,
what do you want to do?
I was listening to some songs and he
takes out the Kansas Angel album,
puts it on and.
Exactly.
Dude,
this sounds
so great.
And we were actually listening to music,
sitting down,
listening to it.
My kids got into vinyl.
They got a,
you know,
like at urban outfitter,
you buy the little,
the setup now and that's where they,
that's where you can get vinyl.
It's,
it's there,
there are some record stores out there,
but that's where they gravitate towards.
Got them this little player and uh,
they just picked out some album covers
dating even know who they were just
like,
this cow,
this cover looks cool,
this speaks to me.
I'm buying this.
I remember telling them that kind of
thing.
Cool cover.
Yep.
That's how I discovered tons of bands.
So they go into the room and you know,
I leave them alone for awhile and they
come back and I haven't come out.
It's like,
what's going on?
I look in there,
there,
you know,
the record players on the floor covers
and stuff strewn out all over the place
and they're laying on the floor
listening to.
It's like,
that is what that was me,
you know?
Uh,
and my,
my daughter comes out and she said,
dad,
you'll never guess what,
like what their songs
on the other side.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It's not a CD,
you know,
I was like,
she discovered some huge thing,
you know?
Wow.
Well that was one of the things that was
not.
What is this vinyl sales outperformed
digital downloads for the first time.
He shows a significant shift in how
people are consuming music.
That's really interesting.
Stick man.
I tell you,
that's just cool in general,
the more ways you can get music to
people,
the better.
Well,
I think the other thing that you were
saying,
it's like it's a whole presentation.
The album cover,
you opened it up,
the inside the artwork,
all that represents your vision of what
you guys are trying to put out.
And that was one of the things that kind
of went away with digital.
Like all of a sudden there were no album
covers,
so the CD was that big,
so you couldn't really,
there wasn't,
you know,
it's like a tiny little piece of art and
if you're downloading it,
you're not even getting that,
you just,
you're just getting the music itself.
Well,
and you would get downloadable artwork
but you're not really looking at the
artwork while you're listening to it on
your mobile device,
you know,
so you know,
the event of sitting down and,
and,
and disappearing into the music,
you know,
being a real music listener,
not while you're driving.
I get it.
It's,
it's keeping you from killing people on
the road,
but when you go home and you sit and you
just get lost in stuff.
Even like those cheap friggin
headphones,
man,
the little earbuds,
my kids were listening to stuff on that.
It's like you guys haven't experienced
music,
like,
good sound here.
Try these headphones on the like,
whoa.
I hear stuff I didn't hear before.
And uh,
but just seeing my kids get excited
about going to a live concert,
you know,
they go there and they absorb it in like
every sense.
You're not just having your ears hear
something and that will never be,
I don't know,
maybe the frigging goggles or some kind
of audio visual stuff will reproduce
live shows,
but there's something about being next
to a sweaty fucker at a Gig and you
know,
they're pushing you or uh,
you know,
seeing someone headbang wildly are
getting thrown over the top of you and
there's just so much smells,
things like that that just can't be
recreated.
So live music.
My daughter,
just like,
I can't believe that guy just pressed a
button on his computer and he's singing
over his own music that's not
performing.
You know,
she discovered that on her own,
hey,
these guys are actually playing their
instruments and they fucked up.
They fucked up a song.
It was so cool.
You know,
I saw something that I wouldn't have,
you know,
really cool like that.
Yeah.
The lip syncing thing,
man,
when you go to see a concert and you
find out that people that lip sanking
that's so disturbing.
It's just what have you done with this
is what is the point of this?
It is disappointing.
What is live performance?
Live performance is supposed to be your
experience in this thing actually
happening.
You're watching this person express
themselves.
Then they're not.
They're not pretending.
You're not supposed to be pretending.
Right?
Are you pretending you're you will get
money back because you're not.
That's not.
That's,
that's pretending.
That's not singing,
not gone to see plenty of shows with my
kids and you can tell it's like,
alright,
the Mike's way over here and they're
still sing in and it's like,
well they have to have the backing
tracks.
Cut.
They're,
they're dancing and they're out of
breath like,
well,
fucking stopped dancing to the song.
I mean are you a dancer or you're a
musician or singer in cardio?
Just start running hills.
It can be Diego to Vail and run up.
The 14 are exactly.
It can be done,
but I've seen shows where there's that
going on and then he'll get real,
you know,
like sit down on a couch plugging and
acoustic and sing out a key and like
really try and struggle with a song or
sing it,
you know,
it's like,
that's natural.
That feels good.
Who would not gravitate towards that
than listening to the album?
I'm going to listen to the album.
A home.
Yeah.
That's why it's cool to just see an
acoustic set sometimes from people you
know,
just like it's as minimal as possible.
You're breaking it down to the bare
bones,
just a guitar and sing it or something,
you know?
Yeah.
That is pretty intimidating.
I tell you when we do like that Neil
young benefit where it's,
you know,
acoustic only and if your frigging neck
naked up there,
dude,
every note is like,
you know,
in every fuck up on the vocal.
It's,
it's great.
I mean it's like when,
uh,
you know,
you go or you're going to be on a TV
thing and they put makeup on you.
It's like,
why are you doing that?
Right?
No,
exactly.
Uh,
so when people see me in person,
they think,
damn,
you're one ugly fuck.
It's like,
no,
I want to be as ugly as possible to
everyone.
So when they see me,
Oh hey,
it's,
you know.
Exactly.
Exactly right.
Yeah.
You're not airbrushed.
You see a photoshop yourself and it's
like,
you know,
they smoothed out all your lines and
you're like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Sometimes
sometimes you gotta to do it or like,
you know,
if you're in a band like I am and the
three guys get the stuff put on and then
I show up,
dude,
oh my God,
I,
you're a shiny.
It's like people going to go fuck this
band.
That dude sweating.
Yeah,
right,
right.
When it comes to the napster thing and
what would happen with Lars,
I feel like there's two different
things.
There's something,
there's what's really happening and this
is how people look at it.
And what's really happening was like all
of a sudden this door got opened up,
this Pandora's box got open,
right?
And you guys were looking at it going,
well,
this is a,
we're going to lose our record sales
like you do.
You understand that like people have
been consuming music in a certain way,
had been paying for music and that
paying for music is supported.
All these people that are a part of this
industry that makes albums,
there's this gigantic thing behind it.
This is all going to go away because you
just put a hole in the bottom of it and
all the money is gonna get dropped out.
But then the way it looks is look at
this rich motherfucker.
You know,
he doesn't,
he doesn't appreciate his fans.
Hey Man,
I can't afford your album right now.
Is it okay if I just download it for
free?
And a lot of people thought,
well,
hey,
people who can afford it will still be
downloading it and then they'll buy it
when they can.
But that wasn't really the case,
was it?
No,
I don't know.
I,
you know,
I'm all for convenience in the
technology moving forward,
getting music out to people is the
important part.
But just make sure the artist gets what
they deserve from it because without
that it's going to become a hobby.
No one wants,
you know,
I don't want to see the paramedics show
up at my house and it's like a hobby for
him.
Hey,
you know,
I'm not really getting paid for what I
think I should get paid for my creation,
but I guess I'll save your life.
You know?
Maybe people didn't relate that to
their,
their career or something equivalent.
I think because the money wasn't
equivalent.
They looked at you guys like,
you guys are already so rich.
What do you give a shit?
There's no way you're going to be broke.
You guys made millions and millions and
millions of dollars to tour all over the
world.
And it became touring thing was way
artists made money then.
Right?
Touring and merchandise.
And that's now how record companies are
stress.
Structuring their deals,
you know,
hey,
we get a piece of your merge in and
touring.
See that's bizarre though.
The record companies,
getting a piece of your touring to me is
very strange and I've seen not just a
piece but an exorbitant amount and that
disturbs me.
Well,
it's the only way they can survive.
No,
they shouldn't be around them because
then you become a parasite because you
don't deserve it.
I mean,
especially now where bands can literally
become gigantic because of Youtube.
We didn't.
Justin bieber become huge just entirely
because of youtube.
Jamie knows,
look at them.
Fucking Justin Bieber Fan.
He hides it.
Hey,
me too.
First I heard him saying,
I thought it was a girl.
I didn't even know it was a.
I didn't know.
Well,
I'll tell you the,
the whole,
uh,
you know,
would you,
would you go up to the artist and take
that out of his pocket?
You know,
would you go into a record store and
just lift that,
steal it,
run out the door with it,
you know,
what'd you do that with?
You know,
okay,
there's,
you know,
there's big corporations that are rich
and would you go walk in and just steal
their stuff?
I mean,
they're software companies that are
massive.
What'd you go in there and just rip
their stuff.
I don't get that mentality.
I don't call me old school,
but you need to earn what you get and if
it gets stolen from you,
it doesn't make any sense that it's hard
to fathom and what it seems like to me,
and I could be talking out my ass,
but the record companies dropped the
ball and the new record companies became
itunes in control at all.
Here's how much we're charging for your
music and here's how much you're going
to get.
Everyone's even.
It's like some communist approach,
you know,
and I,
I don't understand.
I don't understand that.
If we're an artist and we make a lot of
money,
that's up to us.
If we give all our money away to charity
or we throw it back into a movie that
bombs,
which happened,
um,
that's our choice.
We're the fucking artist.
We get to do what we want.
It's our party.
You're invited and we can destroy this
thing if we want.
I don't want you to destroy it.
Yeah.
The itunes distribution models of very
bizarre one.
It's very strange how they've,
they don't know what they're doing.
No one knows what they're doing and you
know,
there was a system that worked and I'm
up for bucking the system and making it
better,
but it didn't,
it didn't get better.
It's like the,
like you said,
the cat got out of the bag and you can't
put it back in,
man.
You just can't.
Um,
so what do you do?
Oh,
you got spotify or you got something
else where streaming's going to help get
the artists their money and it's,
it's,
um,
you know,
companies like that are losing money.
A lot of spotify.
I don't,
I don't know the exact workings and I'm
not going to speak for them at all,
but it's hasn't been figured yet is what
I'm
saying.
It hasn't been figured out how to make a
music model work and there's no one way.
Maybe there will never be one way again
and that's fine,
but it's still unbalanced.
Well this technology continues to evolve
and change is sort of in a lot of ways
like twitter,
like how many millions and hundreds of
millions of people use twitter,
but they can't figure out a way to make
money with it is this very strange thing
where people just want to use stuff,
they don't want to give you any money so
you have to figure out some way to
extract money from all these people
using stuff and if you have a streaming
service,
you know,
and it's free.
It's a free streaming service and I see
some of the fees that they pay artists
for music that's been played millions of
times like wasn't what does that one
song,
I forget who it was like the most played
song on spotify and then they have the
numbers that the guy got for that actual
song and you're like,
well where the fuck is the money going
then?
Right?
Like what?
Well,
you know,
we're talking a lot about money here.
There it is for Almay to,
oh,
he's fucking ads.
This is what's wrong with America.
Looks like you're using an ad blocker.
Yeah.
I'm using an ad blocker to stop this.
You Fuck Jesus Christ had a display
here.
It goes for made only 2 million,
$700,000
in song writing royalties from 43
million plays of his song that I can't
look at the ad because the fucking ad
blocker.
What,
what,
what is that?
Business insider.
Hey,
fuck you.
Business insider.
And you either got it,
you can't have the ads just pop up.
You can't.
Those are gross.
Uh,
it's frustrating I think.
But that's another thing.
That's how they're making money right
away because nobody wants to buy
magazines anymore.
Well,
that's how they're making money.
Not for l,
$3.
Million plays of happy 2000 bucks.
That's fucking crazy.
That's a plane ticket for $43 million.
I mean,
it's nuts.
We talked a lot about money,
but it's not.
I mean,
it's not about the money and it doesn't
mean it shouldn't be anybody's fricking
business.
How much you make,
how much he makes.
I mean,
if you want to reveal it,
fine,
but why is there such a stigma around
being successful?
I don't understand that people will just
want to repeat,
repeat for it.
You know,
there's a disingenuous idea that,
or the disingenuous approach to art if
you're just doing art to make money and
that's what people hate.
People like what are the things that I
loved about your new album is it's
totally clear 100 percent that this is a
real metallica album.
This isn't just some ham and we need to
make some money.
Let's slap together some shitty ideas
and make them metallica album out of it
and we know how to do it.
No,
it's a fucking metallica album.
You know,
and that's because you're creating your
art.
You're not necessarily doing it saying,
hey,
if we do this,
we should be able to make money.
Then that's I think when people think
that someone's just trying to make
money,
it drives them crazy because they,
someone people know in their head that
that's not how great artists created
that you might have.
The money might be a consequence of
great art,
but it's not.
You don't say,
well,
let's make a movie that makes $100,
million dollars.
There's going to be awesome.
No the fuck it's not.
That's gonna be a bunch of Shitty CGI
and explosions and a hot girl and the
guy and the girl kiss at the end and
fuck you.
I saw it all coming.
It's been done before and it's been done
before because you're just slapping
together a formula and that stuff drives
people nuts when you know that someone
is doing something just for money,
so whenever money gets discussed,
people automatically get that sort of
weird distaste,
that God's money,
that fucking money is ruining
everything.
They're going to be doing ballads on
some teenage angst fucking movie next.
Right?
Well,
that's not hard wired,
that's for sure.
No,
no,
we're still.
We're still.
We're men.
We're still searching for.
Still doing it.
Still searching for the right.
The best.
The ultimate riff.
You're still doing it.
That's what's most important.
You're still doing it and it can be
done.
I think when we were kids,
there weren't old rockers.
You know,
I'm 49.
How old are you?
Fifty three.
When we were kids.
Who the fuck was an old rocker?
You know Jerry Lee Lewis is pretty old.
He's still out there doing it.
Chuck Berry's still touring.
Holy Shit,
you know,
but now you got fucking Mick Jagger's
going crazy on stage.
He's still a kid.
Fucking kid.
The last sperm,
the fucking last survivor with one sperm
with the fucking ax wound across his
face,
marches through the battlefield and
punches through that egg.
I made it God damn pirate.
But I mean that guy still out there
smashing it.
Like I've seen him write his fucking
concerts are rockin.
He's got energy.
Not only him,
but the one person that we get compared
to the stone was like,
how long are you going to do this as the
question.
Right,
right.
I don't know when it's.
If it's still fun,
we're going to do it.
When it's not fun,
then we'll let you know.
Yeah.
But yeah,
Mick Jagger and the stones,
Mick Jagger for sure he's out there.
He's doing his thing.
He's,
he's all over the place,
you know,
the stones,
music wise,
uh,
and the rest of the band,
you know,
they're,
they're doing what they've always done,
but it's not the physicality like,
say metallica has.
So,
you know,
uh,
Charlie Watts's not lars Olrick,
you know,
like,
fuck,
you know,
right.
At some point your body's saying,
oh boy,
we can't do this for this long anymore.
Let's take a break.
Uh,
so keeping yourself healthy and fit in a
physical,
mental and spiritual sense.
You got to do all of that for sanity
sake and other bands that are out there
that are doing it,
that angus young is probably the guy or
I definitely take my hat off for that
dude is insane.
And so,
I don't know,
you must sweat gallons every show and
he's,
you know,
he's like the size,
he's like a little dude.
He is in health and he's out.
Where's that water coming from?
How can you sweat,
you sweat your body weight,
you know,
and he's out there headbanging and rock
and I mean,
and he's,
he's up there in age too.
So that's the person,
we're kind of a,
I guess seeing how.
How long can this guy go?
The canary in the coal mine.
He is,
man.
Is he not a fucking brain damage from
that head banging like,
well,
soccer players getting brain dead.
He might,
but he might give a fuck.
Like that's the price you pay.
Take some vitamins,
get back out there,
bitch.
Yeah.
Well I'll tell you,
out of the big four,
know the big four.
Metallica slayer,
megadeath anthrax,
these four bands that are still going
and unbelievably after 35 years myself,
Dave Mustaine and Tom Arrive all had
neck surgery from all of this head.
Neck surgery.
What kind of neck surgery?
Uh,
it was a partial diskectomy in like c,
I think c six.
Okay.
So you had a bulging disc.
It was we pressing on your nerve would
rest on my.
Yeah,
my,
my arm.
I couldn't
pick my nerve.
So it was like making your hands numb.
Yeah.
Well I couldn't pick my arm up.
Did you ever do decompression?
Like spinal decompression chamber?
No.
Spinal decompression.
Like they put a harness on your neck and
they stretch your neck.
Did they do that?
Yeah.
Do you have one of those at home?
I don't need to get one of those
gigantic.
It's so simple.
It's just a harness that you put on
straps,
velcro around it.
It connects to a door at the top of a
door and you just sit down a chair and
it's like you're hanging yourself.
You pull it,
click,
click this and it just stretches.
It carries your weight a little bit on
your neck.
You're still sitting.
You could totally.
That's it.
Like there seat up in that time.
I have one of those in my house.
It's fucking invaluable.
It's so giant because it's the only way
to legitimately stretch your neck and a
lot of spinal decompression.
Lot of bolts discs and the pain and
discomfort associated with it.
You can mitigate a lot of that with one
of those things.
It's big.
I don't have to wear that shirt right
now.
You wear whatever you want to go naked.
I got another thing I'm going to show
you that's called the iron neck.
That'll strengthen your neck up.
We were looking at that.
Yeah.
I'll show you how to do it.
This guy just brought it in last week.
I'm.
I'm obsessed with it.
It's fucking amazing.
And it's also good.
It's not difficult to do.
It's pretty easy to do,
but it's also good for not just
strengthening your neck,
but increasing your range of motion.
Hey,
great.
I can imagine they're all after a while,
man.
Yeah.
Not just that,
but just the posture of your guitar,
you know,
it's,
you're playing really low and you're
down and you're back.
You know,
there's posture stuff,
but I agree that making,
making,
making it straight,
making your back straight is harder now
than it was leaning against the wall and
thinking,
wow,
I don't want to be that old dude.
Punched over the middle of his back is
like a frigging,
you know,
like the,
uh,
you know,
hunchback of Notre Dame or something.
It creeps in on you.
You don't even realize it's happening
until it's too late and then you can't
straighten it back up again.
Right.
Do you exercise?
Yeah.
What do you do?
I got a physical trainer in Vail,
uh,
basically keeping range of motion going
core,
uh,
you know,
lots of hiking,
treadmill,
stuff like that.
I'm not so much,
you know,
power bulking up or anything,
but just trying to stay mobile.
I've got a,
and I'm sure everyone my age has some of
it.
It's a,
you know,
a spinal stenosis where there's calcium
and,
you know,
kind of our threat,
arthritic buildup around the nerves
around your spinal cord.
So keeping that mobile,
keeping things moving.
I go to a holistic healer to who was
breaking up calcium on,
on fingers and toes and stuff.
And uh,
I'm doing all I can do and all I can to
get up there and be angus young still.
Yeah.
Well,
if you're experiencing issues with
stenosis,
two,
that,
that machine can help that a lot.
Strengthen your,
your whole spinal cord.
And I got another thing in the back.
I want to show you.
It's called the reverse hyper.
And actually,
uh,
this is it right here.
It actually helps decompress your body.
Um,
it decompresses your spinal column and
strengthens it at the same time.
It's created by that.
See that guy with the black shirt.
That guy's a fucking psychopath.
Stems,
Louie Simmons,
great guy.
We interviewed him for the podcast.
He's completely out of his fucking mind.
He's been on steroids straight since
1976.
He's never gone off of them,
pointed that lady like something's
happening.
So fuck he's explaining what it does to
your back.
But uh,
that machine man,
anybody with back issues,
any back issue at all because what that
machine does is it allows your back to
actively decompress from the lower back
all the way up to your,
um,
to your neck area and uh,
it,
it strengthens everything and decompress
it.
So it lengthens your spine.
It stretches all that tissue out and
pulls all that,
all the Fascia and all that stuff out.
Like you could see him like
demonstrating in here when this woman
gets up there and see as it goes down,
it's actually pulling your back.
And that's like the only exercise that
I've ever seen that decompresses.
And then on the lift up strengthens all
those muscles.
And then on the way down,
it pulls them down and have a bunch of
different things in the back because
I've had some disc issues myself,
but I took care of all of them without
surgery.
Right on.
But it wasn't.
The doctors are trying to cut me like
they,
that's the immediate thing.
Like,
you're going to need surgery,
get in there,
we'll probably eventually going to have
to have your disks a fuse.
And I was like,
what?
Like wait a minute,
I'm moving around.
Fine.
Like,
why?
How come?
How come you guarantee that it's gonna
get worse?
Like why is it that when you're one at
one state,
they never think you can improve this
with physical therapy and it can get
better.
Their immediate reaction is it's gonna
get worse.
So count on getting the surgery.
Oh,
that's what they know and that's what
they're schooled on.
And uh,
I love the fact that you're giving them
the finger and say,
Hey,
no,
I don't have to go down that path.
I'm going to try it this way.
And uh,
there are lots of different ways to do
that.
And unfortunately mine was,
it was touching the nerve and I couldn't
lift my arm and it was atrophy happening
and so something had to happen.
But my back,
yeah,
I've gone onto,
I've had like,
you know,
a ruptured discs,
a broken ribs going on tour,
you know,
singing with two broken ribs.
Not Fun.
Uh,
but yeah,
the back man when it,
when it hurts,
you turn into a fucking baby man.
I just like,
eh.
No.
You could have like a torn calf muscle
and you limp around,
but you seem to be okay.
But you're back.
You're like,
I can't do anything.
My life's over.
Yeah.
But.
All right,
well go see your,
your torture chamber or your.
Do you do yoga?
No,
no,
no.
You gotta do gotTa get involved?
Yeah,
it seems like it seems fucking.
Seems like everything wrong.
Like housewives,
bullshit.
Maybe gay dude.
I don't care about doing any of that
crap.
If it's going to help me,
it will.
I'm into it.
Anybody over 40 in particular?
Yoga is gigantic especially.
Yeah.
Cool.
Well,
I mean,
I've done things where,
you know,
okay,
we're going to ask your body some
questions and here put this statement
against your chest or here,
what are these colored glasses and you
know,
hey,
here's tuning forks on your body,
you know,
things like that,
I'm totally,
I'm an explorer.
I'd like to.
And if it works,
cool.
If it doesn't work.
Hey,
I tried it.
What was the question you had to ask
your body?
You wrote it down on a piece of paper
and put it to your chest?
Yeah.
What was the question?
Uh,
am I retarded?
Never go full retard.
Like a champagne for that?
No,
it didn't look right.
Uh,
I don't know what the question was.
Like,
why am,
why am I doing this?
Why am I writing a piece of paper and
putting it on my chest?
Something like,
you know,
am I willing to get healthy?
Something like that,
you know,
us,
uh,
I'd like to be friends with my body
instead of abusing it,
you know,
stuff like that.
So well,
the intensity of your performances.
I mean,
I just can only imagine the,
the physical strain that it puts in your
body.
That's why I wanted to ask you about
fitness.
Like you Kinda have to be in shape to do
metallica concerts at 30.
Forget about it.
Fifty three.
Yeah.
Well we have,
we have pet on the road,
uh,
a therapist who will stretch us out.
Do A.
No,
we're all different.
You know,
my back,
my neck,
Robert's calves,
you know,
he's this CAC.
Yeah,
it's like a,
he's like a,
he's these frigging Tarzan,
that guy.
He's gets way
down,
you know,
it.
Surfer calves and finger or his forearms
from playing with his fingers.
They cramp up.
So,
uh,
and then lars largest shoulder or this
one,
you know,
high hat.
Um,
so we've all got our thing,
Kirk's risks and this guy is out there
helping us and you know,
he'll,
he'll give us things to try and work on.
And um,
you know,
we all,
we all have to have our regiments out
here.
It's like you take apart a home on the
road,
you know,
it's not like I need my,
I need my hotel room decorated like my
house,
you know,
bring my bed on tour and not that,
but it's people that can help me out on
the road.
Some people do go crazy like that,
right?
Yeah.
I want you to recreate the a.
and I've heard stories and it's kind of
funny.
Maybe it's true.
Maybe it's not,
I don't want to continue a rumor,
but just hearing that,
yeah,
some of the guys in the stones will have
their decorator come in and,
and they've decorated their hotel room,
like their home or something,
put their favorite things in there and
all that.
And then they're there for a night and
then they go off to the next place and
the decorator meets them in advance and
sets it up at the next spot to,
uh,
yeah,
I mean,
I guess if you're fucking Mick Jagger,
whatever,
do whatever the hell you want.
Your 90,000
years old,
you're still getting chicks pregnant.
Hey,
what kind of reality does that guy live
in Houma to say it's wrong,
man,
you know?
Yeah.
Uh,
you do what you want and feel good about
it when you go to bed and wake up and
go,
okay,
I'm all right.
You know,
that's the main thing,
you know,
if I've gone to bed and say,
man,
that was stupid.
Or actually,
yeah,
the other day it's pretty stupid that I
gotta call this guy and tell him what we
were doing this.
Uh,
oh,
what was it?
Uh,
the Guy Billy on the street,
you know,
that billy on the street with a,
a billy idol,
I think his name is,
and he just,
you know,
he's on the street just running up to
people.
Say,
look,
hey.
Yeah,
like quiz shows.
You like it,
what's the name of Adele's album?
No,
you suck.
And then run off to the next person,
you know,
really manic kind of crazy stuff.
We did that in a store with him the
other day.
We went shopping at a supermarket and a
in a,
uh,
in a shopping cart,
metallics,
pushing a shopping cart around.
He's running up to people going,
hey,
what are you buying today?
What A.
Oh,
you're making a salad.
Hey,
do you want to get pumped up while
you're shopping?
We got metallica here to pump you up.
So we pressed the play button and same
as playing rock joke.
Come on,
we're a park.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And we're filling up their car with
stuff they don't need no fuck.
And um,
uh,
this one guy,
this one guy who was at the salad bar
and he looked like he just took a break
from work,
you know,
it was on his lunch break and I start
filling up a salad with peas and all
kinds of stuff and we're throwing salad
over the place.
And uh,
uh,
I turned around,
did grab some more stuff.
Lars had put dressing on a salad.
I didn't know that.
So at the end when we took off,
I just,
I wanted to just throw it in his face
like it was dry salad and the dressing
when all over him,
he's like,
you fuckers like,
oops,
that backfired.
Okay.
We've gone a little too far.
You know,
I'm 18 again in trashing the hotel room.
Okay.
We're at the supermarket.
She allowed James Wright who organized
this fucking thing.
Oh,
a w.
was it just part of our Promo tour
thing,
you know?
Um,
and uh,
we're trying to do funny,
do cool different stuff.
You know,
some of these shows they're,
you know,
they get wacky and uh,
uh,
I don't know if you saw the,
the metallica playing with the roots on
Jimmy Fallon.
Plan Sandman on the little.
No,
I didn't
see that.
We got little recorders and they know a
little,
you know,
like a little drum sets,
little kids instruments.
That was a lot of fun.
So we're getting,
you know,
getting to have some fun and kind of not
be too serious about all of this.
You know what,
that's cool
thing to see someone who's as big as you
are in a band that's just a goddamn
gigantic monolith,
epic band.
But you guys are silly.
You guys are pretty Goddamn epic.
All right.
I think you know that.
Well,
the fact that here it is,
give me some volume.
What's the matter?
Put it in,
we'll get the roots are good man.
Great Band.
Jimmy Fallon is such a silly guy.
We were having some fun.
Definitely having some fun there.
Well that's,
that's also a cool thing to see from a
fucking hard band too.
I mean,
you guys don't necessarily take.
you obviously take yourself seriously.
You're obviously,
you're serious about what you do.
Take yourself too seriously.
Seriously.
About your art or art.
When we write a song,
it's,
we're serious about this,
but when we go out,
when we play live,
I mean we're,
you know,
we're not,
we're not the best musicians separately,
I would say,
um,
and someone might disagree,
but when you put us together,
something happens and we create
something really cool.
There's an energy.
And I think back from the very
beginning,
like when someone fucked up the song,
we just stopped.
It's like,
Oh man,
let's try it again.
We can do this better.
You know?
And people said with the,
you're not supposed to do that.
Do.
They're not very professional.
It's like,
yeah,
but that's what happened.
I mean,
if we're honest,
we want to do it better and we know we
can,
so we're going to stop it and do it
again,
you know?
Uh,
or I mean,
just like the other day I was like this
frigging brainfart on stage where we're
up there and they play the one,
the intro to one,
which is like this army,
heck you,
you know,
all the war going on.
And then I start this thing and I
started the wrong song.
I started to fade to black instead of a
different song.
I'm standing there going,
what do I do now?
And in like,
this wave of shame comes over you like
you're a bad man.
Know.
And I'm looking over my roadie and
they're going not that song.
And I look at it,
it's like,
okay,
I'll stop it.
And then I went to the other song and
then I'm able later to go up and say,
hey,
you want to hear faded black again?
You know,
you got a joke about it or else you,
you.
It's like you become.
It's like you gotta expose your
vulnerable parts.
People people make.
We'll make fun of that and they'll take
advantage of it sometimes,
but most of the times people will relate
to it.
Like,
ah,
he's human.
He fucked up.
Okay.
You know,
so trusting that there's more,
there's more lifeguards than sharks out
there most of the time.
Yeah.
I think also there's a beat.
People differentiate the big difference
between a mistake and someone who's
careless or doesn't give a fuck.
Very true.
And that's just.
You guys are obviously very serious
about what you do,
but everybody occasionally has a brain
fart.
There's just no getting around it.
I've been in the middle of a UFC
broadcasts and I fucking forget
someone's name and I called their fights
100 times and I can't remember why I
can't remember the name and then for
whatever reason I have to look down at
my notes in there it is,
and I'm just angry with myself.
Just sometimes it just doesn't work and
there's no rhyme or reason to why your
brain doesn't work.
Right?
Sometimes.
So you're tough on yourself.
Oh yeah,
I'm horrible myself.
Yeah.
You say this to yourself that you
wouldn't even say to your worst enemy.
I don't.
There's no words.
I don't just,
it just feelings.
Just I could have a show where I
kill,
but I fuck up one word and one joke and
that's all I can think of.
That's just no way.
If you care about what you do,
that's just part of it.
Absolutely.
And that's it.
There's a healthy part to that and then
moving on from it is,
it's easier now than it used to be.
It would just,
it would live in me for awhile.
Like,
Oh dude,
you forgot the words to that song,
and then it becomes a mental block to
get up there and you go,
Oh shit,
like,
uh,
you know,
like a kicker or something,
a guy going to kick a field goal.
It's like,
Oh,
I missed that one.
I can't believe I did.
Then the next one,
oh my God,
now it's a thing,
you know?
Oh,
so getting over those mental.
Yeah.
Fighters a fight and then
they come back and then you see the
discomfort.
You can see the confusion and the fear
and that's,
uh,
that's one of the side,
I think,
psychological issues or some of the
hardest issues that people ever overcome
and it's just literally like a pattern
of thought in your mind or if you just
decide that you're not as good as you
used to be,
you can manifest that in there.
Like physically you can do all the same
things.
That is so cool.
So
crazy.
The power of thought.
The power of my mind is it's pretty
dangerous at times and being creative,
a makeup,
all kinds of crap,
you know,
like a large largest doing that just to
fuck with me.
I know it.
And then you talk to them later.
It's like,
what are you talking about?
What?
Yeah,
that's,
that's pretty.
It's,
it's,
it's a curse and a gift that creativity,
you know,
how hard was it for you to get sober?
A fear was a big motivator in that for
me,
you know,
losing my family was.
That was,
that was the thing that scared me so
much.
That was the bottom I hit that my family
is going to go away because of my
behaviors that I brought home from the
road.
I got kicked out of the house by my
wife.
I was living on my own somewhere and you
know,
I did not want that.
And maybe it's part of my upbringing,
you know,
um,
my family kinda does sitting graded when
I was a kid,
you know,
father left,
my mother passed away.
I live with my brother and then Kinda
just all like the family,
you know,
where'd my stuff go?
Where,
where it just kind of floated away and I
do not want that happening,
you know,
no matter what's going on,
we're gonna talk this stuff out and make
it work.
You know,
and my wife's have the same,
uh,
same idea,
same thought that,
you know,
her,
her family,
she was the invisible kid too,
you know,
so we relate a lot.
So there's no way we're going to let you
know any argument,
get in the way or just,
you know,
we're survivors,
we're survivors and we're gonna.
We're gonna talk through it.
No matter how much.
And you know,
she,
she did the right thing,
she kicked my ass,
right the hell out of the house,
you know,
and um,
that scared the shit out of me.
So.
And she said,
hey,
you're not just going to the therapist
now in this nuts talking about this.
You got to go somewhere and sort this
shit out.
So that's what I did.
So Rehab did Rehab really worked for me.
Helen,
jeff to go for a while.
What worked for me was a seven weeks
someplace like basically tearing you
down to bones,
ripping your life apart.
Anything that you thought about yourself
or what it was,
anything you thought you had,
your family,
your career,
your,
anything gone strip you down to just,
okay,
you're,
here's how you were when you were born.
You were okay,
you're a good,
good person.
Let's get back to that again.
And then they slowly rebuild you.
And then I went to a,
uh,
another they call them aftercare places.
I went there to a couple different ones
and they fine tune stuff and get
integrated back into life.
Because when you're in this cocoon and
your frigging raw,
I mean,
I was raw meat when I came out and you
can see it in some kind of monster
movie.
I was pretty raw still.
I didn't know what I could or what I
should or shouldn't do,
you know.
Um,
so the,
the last place we went to was a place
that helps relationships.
So they got me and my wife together and
we'd see people separately and then come
together and talk about what we did and
communication frigging saved my life
saved,
uh,
our family.
Um,
and working through that stuff.
So very grateful for my wife.
She's the one that didn't ask for this
shit.
She walked through fire with me and we
walked out together stronger,
way stronger than we ever would have
been before.
And you know,
my kids know my story,
my kids know my struggles and they
respect that.
They respect me and a different way.
I don't have to tell them what to do all
the time or just be like,
I'm this.
I can say sorry.
I can tell them,
hey,
here's what happened when I did that.
And you know,
I don't need to preach to them.
They got their own stuff,
but now they,
now they goof with me.
I ruined my trust with my family and now
by some miracle they are goofing with
me.
It's like,
Dad,
shut up.
What do you get them like,
come on,
you know,
your overblowing this your way out of
dad,
you're taken up way too much space here.
Okay.
So they helped me and I realized that
there is help in a loving way.
How long have you been sober now?
15.
Fifteen years.
Did it start out when you,
when you first started doing it,
did it feel like as you broke through
and you,
you know,
you went to therapy and you got out of
Rehab and you're going through this
whole thing.
Was there a,
like a shaky leg period where you're
like,
man,
do I know who I am anymore?
Oh absolutely.
That was it.
That was,
that is,
you know,
the power of the mind and how,
here's how my life works.
And to actually just completely throw
that away and start over,
it's like,
well,
wait a minute,
who am I without this?
Um,
uh,
I can't talk to people.
I'm like,
I'm anxious,
I'm shy.
I'm all of the stuff that I thought
booze was helping me with,
or you know,
you know,
booze,
drugs,
women,
a shopping,
eating,
gambling,
you know,
there's so many things that can manifest
out that it's,
it all goes back to one core thing.
It's like I don't,
I don't really know who I am.
So it took years and years and years to
figure out,
okay,
I like that.
That's part of me.
And this is part of me,
the anger,
the,
you know,
the quirkiness,
the dork part of me,
all these little things that make me,
I got to hug them,
I accept them,
you know,
and quit running from them and
pretending like I am some immovable
object on stage,
that's tough and you know,
nothing can do,
you know,
nothing going to hurt me.
But inside,
you know,
it's kind of a cliche saying that,
the harder that external shield,
the softer the inside and the more
vulnerable and,
and balancing that,
you know,
almost like you're concentrating so much
on the outside that you ignore the
inside.
Totally,
totally.
And then forget what I really want and
then you lose yourself in that other,
that other person and yeah,
being in a band,
certainly a accelerated that,
you know,
there's,
there was drink and drugs and all kinds
of stuff just thrown at you all the time
and it's starts off as a fun little
thing and then it turns into whiskey and
escape and then all of a sudden you
don't really,
you don't remember why you're out there
doing stuff.
I went on tour just so I could go to the
Strip club,
you know,
hey,
we're going to this place,
you know,
and overcoming a drink here.
And you knew all that stuff.
But the actual playing on stage,
it Kinda got forgotten about a little
bit,
you know,
it was,
we get caught up in the rockstar stuff
and there's a,
there's a song on this album hell Motha
into flame that directly talks about the
how fame can be this crazy drug and it
can completely take you over if you let
it,
you know,
you're searching for that thing that's
gonna save you and it's,
it's you,
it's in you.
It's already there,
you just gotta you just gotTa find it
and accept it.
Well you,
you're very down to Earth Guy,
which is very unusual for someone who's
as famous as you are.
And that's one of the reasons why I
wanted to talk to you about this because
it seems like,
like right now you're,
you,
you know,
you can be,
you,
you're just in that.
But what it seems like for someone who's
as famous as that,
who gets on stage and you know,
for thousands of people just don't want
fucking crazy and you're up there.
I mean,
that has got to be intoxicating and
confusing and oftentimes I feel like
people are a prisoner to whatever image
that either they projected initially or
it becomes how the public perceives them
because of all their success and because
of the fact they go on stage and 100,000
people go fucking ape shit.
What,
what does that like trying to like find
yourself while you're also
kind of worshiped?
Right.
Well enjoy.
Do you hit it?
I mean it's the transitions from road to
home or always somewhat difficult.
It's like there's a,
there's a ptsd that goes along with it.
You know,
you are,
like you said worshiped,
you know,
there's a lot of,
where do I get my validation?
Really that's where I have to step back
and say,
okay,
am I who these people say I am or think
I am.
They have their own vision or version of
me,
just like I had my own version of Lemmy,
you know,
this,
this thing that it was strong and you
know,
these people expect me to be a certain
way and when you,
when they meet you in normal life,
you're sitting with your family eating
or your frigging in the supermarket,
you know,
throwing salad on some guy,
you're a people want you to do the thing
you do,
you know,
hey headbang,
jump up on the salad bar and rock out or
something is food.
Music does that to me.
Music playing music with these guys does
that to me.
But when I'm not doing that,
I'm just a dude,
you know,
and they don't want that,
that it,
it hurts them.
It scares them.
Like,
wait a minute,
um,
I need you to be this certain way.
It makes me feel secure.
So when you're not that I,
you know,
I don't want to sign stuff.
I don't want to take pictures,
selfies with people.
I want to shake your hand and I don't
want to talk with you.
I want us.
Hey,
who are you?
What do you do?
Here's what I do.
You know,
people think they know me because of the
music and all the interviews and all the
stuff.
I get that,
but I don't know you.
So when you come up and say Doula,
you know,
I want to know you because we're at a
disadvantage here.
If you get swamped by people and they
all want to take pictures.
How do you,
how do you handle that?
Oh,
I,
I gotta leave.
I mean,
there's the anger part of me that I
still wrestle with and things get
stupid.
Uh,
and um,
it's like,
it's a fight or flight thing,
man.
It like I'm being attacked.
Wait a minute.
You don't get overwhelmed by all the
people.
Yeah.
Uh,
it's,
it's just so weird.
It's so weird.
We're,
we played in front of half a million
people and a million people.
And where was that?
This was in Russia.
This was a shit in the airfield.
Oh my God.
So we've done that.
What the fuck was that like?
Um,
it was a sea C of Russian people.
I mean,
that's what it was,
that this was in 1991,
91 91 when the,
you know,
the curtain came down and all of that
and a Time Warner had a uh,
uh,
they wanted to basically get their foot
in the door and so they were created a
free concert.
Uh,
it was,
it was a ACDC,
us,
Pantera and I think maybe a local band
or some other bands.
I'm sorry if I can't remember,
but they flew us in there.
We landed in this airfield.
Oh,
Motley crew was on it,
landed in this airfield and as far as
the eye could see it when it was a free
concert and it was just people and we
get on stage and do what we do.
But there were,
it was military,
you know,
military and the front.
Look at that photo.
Holy Shit.
Jamie,
go full screen with that.
Don't just go with that one.
What in the fuck?
Oh my God.
That's insane.
That it.
Is that the one?
That might be something else,
but it looks a little newer,
but it says here it was from 91 mosque
house.
Wow.
That's pretty remarkable.
And there were.
Imagine a sea of people like that and
see there's a helicopter helicopter
flying over people.
I mean,
my God,
if that thing goes down,
man,
it could be chopping up photo.
We can go right up there.
That one onstage facing those people.
Oh my God.
That is fucking insane.
That helicopter would come down close
and they were yelling at people like
stop.
You know,
people were moshing are going crazy.
They didn't know what that was.
Oh Wow.
It was like a fight.
I freaking communist country man.
And was like,
wait,
people are getting out of order.
This is chaos.
He didn't have the Internet then either.
No Way.
They didn't know what to expect of that.
So there are people throwing,
hitting people from the,
from the helicopter.
And down on the front there,
there were guys in uniforms,
you know,
there was no police military.
Same thing,
you know,
so they're standing there and their
uniforms and after like three or four
songs,
they're like,
fuck this.
And they took off their stuff and then
their headbanging and having a good
time.
So we saw the transformation of,
you know,
uh,
closed down society to freedom right
before us individually and in people.
It was awesome.
What does it feel like to stand in front
of 500,000
people?
What does this sound like?
What does the sound of their roars like?
Pretty massive.
I'm obviously,
you know,
I lost count it land on 300 and
something thousand,
but I tell you,
and they don't speak your language.
That's just such a,
that's the power of music,
man.
That's a language in its own.
It's connects people.
It is so cool.
So yeah,
we went to a place that no one spoke
English or people were telling us,
you know,
I learned English from your lyrics.
Like,
Oh shit man,
I failed English just so you know,
I didn't do so well in school.
It's pretty bizarre.
Yeah,
that's intense.
that is intense.
That's a,
that's an experience that almost no
one's prepared for.
I don't think,
I thought,
I don't think there's a single human
being that can do that and not be
somewhat
affected by it or at least need a lot of
decompression,
lot of downtime to sort of sort that
out.
Which.
Hence Vale.
Yeah.
It's like you go out into the mountains,
nature doesn't give a shit who you are,
Mother Nature will kick your ass,
you know,
and leave you frozen and,
last.
When did you start hunting?
Well,
I think it started out my dad was a
hunter that I remember him,
skin and deers in the,
in the garage and in southern California
here.
Skeet shooting probably started with
that skeet and trap.
And then uh,
uh,
went duck hunting with my buddy up in
Colusa and San Francisco area and then,
hey,
we're going on a pig hunt,
let's go.
And then.
So it was slowly the animal got bigger
and bigger and a really,
really enjoyed it.
Enjoyed the,
the,
you know,
the Guy Hang,
just get away and uh,
and just,
you know,
get scared together.
The guy hangs a big part of it.
It's awesome.
It is so cool.
Yeah.
Making fun of each other and you know,
all the,
all the stuff that you don't get to do,
you know,
you just,
you just go and hang and uh,
you know,
I like getting scared.
I like it and scared out there.
It's like,
wait a minute,
I'm,
you know,
I got this,
60 pound backpack on and I just came
from sea level and I'm up here at 11,000
feet and I don't feel very good guys.
How the fuck am I going to get off this
mountain?
I can't do it.
They're like,
yeah,
you can come on and it will carry you
off if that's what it takes.
Like,
okay.
Yeah,
it's a truck is,
you know,
it's like a three hour hike to the,
to the three hour hike to the spike camp
and then another two hours to the base
camp.
You know,
you can do it and stuff like that,
you know,
pushing you to limits that you didn't
know you could go to.
Yeah.
I saw you had a guitar that had a camera
on it.
Oh yeah.
This dude's deep.
It's awesome.
You're deep
dude.
I love the coolest stuff.
Yep.
I got turned onto it by those guys and
yeah,
you know,
it can get pretty cold and scary up
there and it's,
it's fun to.
You
presents to me this really interesting
sort of,
uh,
integration of technology and a almost
like gadget geek mindset applied to
hunting to make the very best stuff.
Yep.
So as soon as I saw that you got gotta a
cool pattern on your guitar,
I'm like,
ah,
he's in deep.
Yeah,
we contacted them.
It's like,
Hey,
can we borrow your pattern?
It's pretty fucking cool.
Uh,
yeah,
I love it.
And how often do you get out?
Well,
yeah,
you know,
at least a co,
uh,
probably,
you know,
a couple of weeks every year is what I
get to do a in
obviously if it's elk season in
Colorado.
Um,
and then there's deer season in
California and Turkey season.
So.
So do you get to hunt near Vail where
you live?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
On elk up there.
Oh my God,
it was twice as many elk as any other
state in the country.
It is amazing.
And you know,
from the house,
are you dropping the kids off at school?
Just drive up the road a little bit and
be spotting,
you know,
hey,
there's some elk up there and you know,
where the kids go to school,
there's a,
there's a sheep herd,
you know,
just up in the mountains like wow.
Oh my God,
it'll take me about 45 years to draw
that tag.
But you guys will start to get those
points up.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So that's,
that's another good reason to live in
Colorado,
right?
Absolutely.
Out there near,
I mean,
mule deer,
white tails.
I mean that's a pretty game.
Rich state.
Yeah,
the elk,
I mean,
you know,
I liked,
I liked the venison elk.
S probably the thing I would eat
nonstop.
Yeah.
People who have never tried it before.
Really the,
I mean you can get it in a restaurant
but you're getting it from New Zealand
and it's not going to be as fresh and
it's not the same,
but it's an unbelievable meet will
pulling it out of your freezer and
making it there for your kids.
I mean there's nothing,
there's no,
nothing more organic than that.
Especially when you know specifically
where it came from.
You were there?
Yeah.
This is not mixed up with some other
crap from some other farm or something.
This is it.
This has been cut and prepared for you.
So I see that massive thick bastard out.
And your latest one.
Yeah.
Data something.
Boy,
where is that?
I want to get ranch.
Oh,
I should've let you guess.
No,
I was going to get New Mexico.
that's from here to California to hone
ranch.
They put rocky mountain elk into home
ranch in the 19 fifties and because
California it's a about a half hour
outside of Bakersfield,
so it's sorta like mid California and
because of that it's not cold again.
They get snow up there,
but not enough snow where the elk have
to struggle for food.
So they eat a lot.
Yeah,
lot of mount lines up there though.
They have a massive,
massively thick.
It's a big animal.
Yeah,
he was huge.
He was like a thousand pounds.
It's a big ass elk,
but blow.
That one was a rifle.
Yeah.
I've shot one there last year with a bow
this year I went with a bow.
We unsuccessfully hunted for five days
and pulled out a rifle and got it done
in an hour.
I go back and forth with the bowl.
It's not cheating.
I mean it's,
it's hunting,
but if you want some really hunting the
best way to go.
I am a meat hunter and that's the way to
do it,
you know.
And New bowhunt hunt a the on my ranch
at home in California.
Uh,
it's just tough.
It's tough with the black tail,
you know,
you've got a fairly small deer too.
Yeah,
that's pretty tough.
I just liked pulling it.
I like target practicing and stuff and
you know,
I have gone bowhunting.
I'm taking a pretty nice
alk with it when it's the Rut.
I mean that.
Yeah,
it's so amazing and it scares the shit
out of you and the screening and friggin
froth
beast coming,
running down at you with a ready to kick
your ass or fuck you.
Yeah.
It's a pretty intense moment.
Right?
Um,
but I've missed some stuff so much and I
just,
you know,
I'd rather use A.
I want to get the animal down and done.
Yeah.
So rifles,
definitely the best way to do that.
But bow I bow hunting requires so much
more discipline.
It's just,
it's a constant pursuit,
but for me it's a great meditation.
Just the practice of archery.
Not,
not even just bow hunting.
I'm,
I'm a big fan of just I'll have to do
it.
Like I'll leave here,
I'll go home,
I'll shoot 100 hours.
Cool.
Yeah,
just to just clean my head out.
It's a good way to just [inaudible] you
can't think about anything else other
than that target in order to do it
right.
Especially shooting at like 70 yards or
something long.
Yeah.
So what Bo?
I saw you gotta I use a white hoyt.
Yeah.
I have a white pro defiant.
It's the newest model just to fucking
awesome bow.
This is the coolest thing about bose is
that unlike rifles,
I mean rifles,
the technology at such a high level,
but I have a rifle from three years ago.
That's awesome.
It's just as good,
but both from three years ago it's.
Well,
it's like a little behind the times,
you know,
you got some new technology,
you could still use it,
you could still kill something with it,
but the newest stuff,
they did the technology and bows,
they essentially innovate every year.
I agree.
Yeah.
And yeah,
I had a,
yeah,
had a matthews from three years ago and
I went in to get it tuned up and the guy
says,
oh my God.
It's like,
you know,
a computer that's a few years old.
Wow.
It's dude.
If you want to get hooked up with this,
if you want to get hooked up with coin,
I'll have one sent to you.
Okay.
I'll look it up.
I got,
I got to matthews that I really love and
you know,
who knows next year,
like you said,
the technology,
just the way they pull,
the way they balance and all that stuff
that,
like you said,
with a gun,
you know,
guns,
guns have come a lot of wastes the long
ways too.
I got this awesome fierce gun that uh,
you know,
carbon fiber barrel and it's super
lightweight for packing in,
you know,
it's down to like six pounds with a
scope on it.
So yeah.
Lightweight.
Good.
Yeah.
If you go in like sheep hunting or
something like that,
you're going way up into the mountains.
Like I know guys who cut the bottom off
of their toothbrush in order to save
weight.
Literally they do everything they can.
They cut every ounce,
bring it toothbrush for the kid to brush
your teeth up in the mountain.
You don't brush your teeth,
they're going to smell your stinky ass
fucking breath before anything.
That's probably the first thing they
smell.
That's why I'm in successful guys who
actually eat,
like they'll take pine leaves and chew
them up inside their mouth just so that
their breath doesn't come off as some
meat eating monster Predator to a deer.
Interesting.
Yeah.
I think that's probably like one of our
big smells
is the breath,
you know,
bio and then your breath.
A lot of people smell breath smells
worse than their bio.
Right.
You've got to think.
Especially old old guy,
old guy with rotten insides.
Yeah.
All that fucking funk.
So you spray up,
you do all that stuff and get killed.
I don't spray up.
No.
I,
uh,
I've used.
Oh,
Xanax,
you know those,
uh,
ozone things in a tree stand.
I've used that where they,
they blow ozone on you and it confuses
the scent that actually works.
It's very bizarre.
It has to be directly on you.
And the ozone somehow attaches itself to
your scent molecules.
And then when the deer gets it,
he's like,
what in the fuck is this?
But it doesn't blow off all those red
flags where he just wants to,
you know,
he smells a Predator and he wants a
bolt.
Right?
Yeah.
Wow.
Well,
I guess it'd be,
you could see the results of it if
you're in the same spot year after year
or something.
But I'd never know if that stuff works
because we're traveling,
doing different stuff,
different places all the time.
Well most of the hunts I go on our spot
and stalk.
So that's not really.
It doesn't really apply.
But in that sense when you're doing
something spot and stalk,
you just have to play.
The wind.
Wind is going towards them.
You're fucked.
They're just,
that's what they're designed for.
I mean they can smell things.
The way I describe it to people is like,
you know how you could smell a skunk if
it got killed like five blocks away.
That's how a deer can smell.
You can smell,
they can smell you like a skunk.
Like they're like,
fuck,
let's get outta here.
They,
they smell skunk,
they bolt.
But I've seen them smell you from 100,
200 yards out and they just catch your
wind like boing boing.
Fuck this bound away.
So brush your teeth,
you get to bottom teeth,
bro.
Thanks for the tip.
Probably a good idea.
Fifty three.
I got to tell you to brush her teeth.
It's hard to tell Rockstar to do
anything.
Yeah,
I mean that's one of the things that
some people like about hunting.
So you don't have to wash it,
just go out there and wear the same
goddamn closed for five,
six days.
And that doesn't send off a signal.
Oh it's.
It certainly will.
But you're wearing Merino wool,
especially like base layers.
It actually can be.
That absorbs most of the smell.
So you think the baby wipes do good or
bad?
Well,
a baby wipes pro.
It's probably better not to smell like
shit.
Especially human shit.
And he'll like a fake cleaning product,
either fake cleaning product won't.
I think anything odd to a deer,
it's probably not good.
But I think there's probably specific
Predator smells that we exist,
you know,
unless you're like a strict vegetarian.
And also hunt,
I would imagine,
nick,
you smelled terrible.
You can probably smell like a killer.
Yeah.
I don't know what they're smelling.
You know,
I would like to know,
like if they could tap into the mind of
a deer when it smells a person,
like what?
What alarms go off.
That would be bizarre.
Like the,
you know,
think the red flag of the Cape on the
bowls.
Like it's not really red,
it's just something's moving,
you know,
what do they see?
What do they hear?
What do they smell?
Yeah.
I guess once you figure that out then
it's really on how much.
How much shit did you have to deal with
when there was that,
the blowback from that?
The hunt show,
you know?
Uh,
it,
it's like I wanted to get into
voiceovers so that I took the Gig.
They have a great voice for it.
It was,
it was,
I didn't even know it was your voice
while you're doing.
It was kind of interesting.
Like it's,
you know,
you did it in a very professional
manner,
but it was a very controversial show
because it was a grizzly bear hunting.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And well,
you know,
I took the Gig,
I wanted to,
I wanted to get into the voiceover
stuff.
So that was offered to me and yeah,
I probably had,
it could have had a choice whether I did
it or not,
but that's what that was.
And I think the main,
the main head happened when I did that
show and then we went to go do
Glastonbury,
which is like the ultimate,
like a celebration of a English hippie
dumb.
And they somehow caught wind that I'd
been a,
you know,
always a hunter.
And he did this show and uh,
and it was like boycott Metallica,
you know,
don't play the show.
We don't want that.
And Wow,
you know.
Uh,
so what we did was we made a,
we made this silly video.
There's always something going on in
England where,
you know,
there's a,
there's something,
there's a controversy that's going to
happen with the,
you know,
the,
uh,
so when an artist shows up,
they do something,
they,
they want something special.
So what they want.
So the fact that I was,
you know,
I did this bear hunting show and so we
made this movie,
uh,
about uh,
it was a guy in England put this movie
together that,
um,
it depicted old school English hunt
huntsman,
you know,
they're on horseback.
Fox hunters,
you know,
took doctor in our release,
release the Fox and all the hounds go
and they go galloping through the,
uh,
the,
the English countryside,
and they come to a spot and they start
getting shot at and it's,
these bears come out of the woods and
they've shot the hunters and they become
the hunter and the crowd loved it.
You know,
they.
Oh yeah,
right arm,
the bears,
you know,
uh,
so it Kinda just instantly diffused all
that bullshit and you know,
when you're able to,
like we said earlier,
make fun of yourself and make fun of
controversy.
Then it just,
it kind of goes away and then you just
get on,
you know,
get,
get back to business,
you know,
what is it frustrating when they were
distributing that picture that wasn't
even you?
There was a photo of some guy that
looked kind of like you in front of this
giant brown bear.
Well,
let me just told him,
told me about them,
that they're ignorant and that's not
even me.
So,
you know,
there,
there are people out there that want to
just,
just want to throw the fuel on the fire
and make it crazier and get upset about
stuff and uh,
you know,
um,
I,
I got no control over that man,
you know,
once it's out there,
I don't want to spend all my time
justifying what I do or don't do it.
It's not even something that I did,
you know.
So yeah.
It's a waste of time.
Do you bear hunt at all?
I did.
But now I wear clothes.
Do you hunt?
Bear?
That was really stupid,
man.
Sorry.
I like stupid jokes.
Do you hunt bear?
Uh,
I did.
I went,
I went to Russia,
went to Khan Chaka and hunt bear.
Yeah,
it was a,
it was a crazy,
crazy adventure.
Was it brown bear or what are the,
what they have up there?
Yeah,
it was brown.
Bear it wouldn't eat any of it.
No,
no I did not.
And that's one regret I have and I mean
getting the meat.
I mean,
for some reason they didn't allow you to
bring meat from Russia into America,
but we did have meat there.
They had meat from other bears and so
that's how we sustained ourselves out in
the middle of the shot is brown bear.
Tastes like,
you know,
bear doesn't taste great to me.
This super fatty for sure.
Uh,
this,
this was less fatty because it was
spring bear and then,
you know,
they were out,
they hadn't,
they just come out of hibernation.
So he had a,
I wouldn't,
it's not my favorite thing,
so I'll probably wouldn't hunt it again
because I do like to eat what I want.
I want a harvest so it wasn't,
wasn't great,
but we had links.
We had all kinds of different stuff
there that they,
you know,
they right in the middle of nowhere.
Links.
Yeah.
What does that taste like?
It tastes like chicken.
Everything tastes like chicken.
Uh,
you know,
it depends on how you cook it.
I mean,
it's meat and it tasted like meat and we
were in this little little hut that was
super short because,
you know,
it's really,
really cold out there.
And there was like about eight feet of
snow.
And uh,
yeah,
you're in this little hut that's really
short to keep warm,
you know.
And uh,
the,
the hunter,
the guides out there,
they had ak 47,
you know,
we were,
it was pretty scary,
you know,
we took a military helicopter,
probably flew two hours in this thing
that looked like it,
it survived world,
you know,
one and two,
well it wasn't around World War One but
survived world war two and it was,
you know,
exhaust down the side and no seats and
we're sitting on the metal floor and
we'd get dropped off in the middle of
this nowhere place.
And these guys have snowmobiles and
there's,
you can't get around because the snow
was so thick.
You needs snowmobile and the guide show
up in their,
you know,
their,
here's
Russians with AK 47.
We're Americans high,
you know.
Hey,
common.
Is it that they have these hunts out
there?
It's so they knew what they were doing
this,
this is a normal thing they did,
it was set up,
you know,
I was like,
the,
um,
through the safari club,
you know,
and,
uh,
it was just one of those crazy things
like,
hey,
I'm going to try this and get scared.
And I was,
wow,
listen man,
you gotta get Outta here because I know
you're a,
you're supposed to leave it to.
It's a couple minutes later than that.
So,
uh,
thanks for doing this man.
I really appreciate it.
It was great meeting you.
It was great talking to you and uh,
it was just awesome conversation.
But likewise,
brother,
appreciate you and,
uh,
keep doing what you're doing,
man.
I will.
You all right.
See if folks.